[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous video we were discussing
about this simply connected region
and in this video we're going to discuss
the multiple connected region
so as i had mentioned earlier uh
basically when you have this kind of a
two dimensional region and you have
holes inside it represented by these
these regions uh this is referred to as
a multiple connected region as opposed
to the fact uh
or to the situation where we would have
no holes which would be
simply connected okay so what do we do
or what we have
in terms of the frontal stress function
formulation
that is different for this multiply
connected region which is different from
the simply connected region
well first of all let us consider the
governing equation that is simply del
square psi equal to minus 1
and this governing equation remains
unchanged whether it is for the simply
connected region or the multiply
connected region
it's the same thing next very
importantly we had earlier mentioned
that psi is equal to constant on the
periphery
this was our general conclusion from the
theoretical development
i must be a constant now in the simply
connected region
what we had said was that since there
was only one periphery involved
we took the uh we were free to consider
the simplest uh consideration for that
psi
uh on the on that on that single
periphery which was
on that psi is equal to zero but we no
longer have that luxury
in the present in the uh in the case of
this multiply connected region
so what do we do well it is still true
that over
each of these peripheries individually
okay so if you consider this periphery
the psi is a constant here
if you consider this periphery this is a
constant here if you consider this
periphery the psi will be a constant
over this entire thing the psi will be a
constant over this entire thing
so that much remains all right okay so
this general uh conclusion that we had
arrived from our general theoretical
development that the
sign must be a constant of the periphery
that remains true
but uh but we must also appreciate the
fact
that these constants that i had just
mentioned they must be of different
values
okay so it's a constant here it's a
constant here but these two constants
are different
so also this constant would be a
different this constant will be a
different value
okay so they are all different values
however to keep things
still as simple as possible what we can
still do is that over the entire outer
periphery
we can still consider the psi to be 0
there it really doesn't change anything
because uh suppose you consider
a situation like this that okay let me
let me name the contours
the the different contours that are
present here as uh
let's say that the outer contour is c0
this one is c1 this one is c2
this one is c3 and if you have other
contours so on and so forth
so on c0
suppose suppose we say that psi
is equal to 1 okay
so this is just like a hypothetical
example then
c has over c1 psi
over c 2 i is equal to
2.5 and over c 3
i is equal to
now instead of this you think whether it
would really make any difference
if i change my baseline such that
i is equal to zero over c naught okay so
what i do is that
that on each of these psi
i just subtract or from each of this
side i subtract 1
so this becomes 0
this becomes 2 this becomes 1.5
and this becomes 3 so overall just by
changing the baseline
it really doesn't change anything
because again i want to emphasize here
that because in the expressions for the
shear stresses
sigma xz and sigma yz which ultimately
we have to find out in terms of this
frontal stress function
that connection is through the presence
of the derivatives
similarly this governing equation they
all uh it involves them
involves the derivatives okay so
what what is usually done is that on the
outer periphery
on the outer periphery i
is taken as 0.
so that is one less thing that we have
to worry about
over the other contours if this is just
a made-up hypothetical example
but in a real problem situation
even if we say that on c0
outer periphery psi is taken as 0 but we
still would not know a priori what the
values of these constants would be over
the c1 c2 and c3
we really have to actually find those
things or they are unknown
so on the other peripheries
inner contours
i
is a constant
on each of them
but
the constant values themselves
are not known so we have to solve for
them
all right
now uh depending on the problem
at hand we can approach this situation
in different ways uh and you know
as we go on to do problems you know and
and
because of the slightly more complicated
geometries that will be cons
considering uh for example
but even if you consider a the simplest
of example which is the
circular annulus it does involve a
little bit of integration
so we were not doing this by hand
because that would be just unnecessarily
time consuming
we'll just go over to uh i'll just
illustrate them by some
on using symbolic python
you can also the people who are not
enrolled in this course
can directly take a look at the
github repository the link for which i
will provide in the description below
but even before we go into such examples
there is a couple of points which is
extremely important to note
so remember
the all important torsional rigidity so
in the case
so let me just write down the expression
here
the general expression it is minus twice
g
integration x n x
plus y and y
sorry about that
y and y times i
over the periphery plus
4g integration over the entire domain
that is an integration with respect to
the area
all right now when we were considering
the simply connected region
because we had the liberty of choosing
this psi
to be equal to 0 over the single
periphery available
this entire first term reduced to 0
but now we don't have that luxury so
it will be better if we subdivide
this integration in this form
so we say minus twice g
integration over the contour d0
this this entire thing
yes plus
p1 this entire thing
yes plus
yes and so on and so forth
okay because i'm writing this as dot dot
dot because
in general it can have more than these
three inner contours also
the last one that remains unchanged
now if we just considered this first
integration
over the c naught contour which is the
outer one
over this you see we have this
expression x and x plus y and y
times c this c we have already
considered to be zero
specifically over the c naught so
this integration is equal to zero
so as i had mentioned earlier one less
thing to worry about
but these other ones the
only thing that we can
the or the only simplification that we
can
do over here is to
take this psi outside this integration
because that psi would be a constant
value
over each of these contours c1 c2 c3 etc
that's the only luxury that we can
afford
so what we will end up
with is this thing summation
i is equal to 1 up to as many inner
um
so i'll put this as
i is equal to 1 to n
where you note that actually what we
have
is this n it represents uh
the n inner contours but in total
we do have n plus one total number of
contours
because the outer one is also a contour
okay so
actually the index is going from 0 to n
you see this
0 up to n it just so happens that we
have considered the psi
to be 0 on c1 that is why the first
or the zeroth contour it does not
contribute all right
so the expression is i i
integration over the c
ith contour x n x
plus y and y
e s plus
4g
all right okay
now uh this is just one of the points
which i had wanted to
mention this is one one level of
simplification
but we have to be extremely extremely
careful about something else also
and that is about about the nature of
this
integration well
the point is like this when we
carry out this kind of the cyclic
integration
over the outer periphery okay so this is
something
which we have to keep in mind
specifically when dealing with
multiply connected region okay this is a
very very special consideration
uh which has to do with the
with the back end mathematics of of such
integrations i won't go into too much
detail but
in terms of the problem solving what we
need to do is this
that when we are doing the integration
over the
outer domain we are actually proceeding
in a clockwise fashion
but when we are doing the integrations
over this
inner contours we are not we are not
going to go
uh just like anti-clockwise rather we
are going to go
clockwise okay so i repeat for the outer
periphery
of the cross section we are going to go
uh or we need to go
anti-clockwise for the inner peripheries
for each of these
we have to go clockwise we have to go
clockwise we have to go clockwise
so let me mark that out
by right writing like this
okay so the arrows depict the
uh the sense in which the
uh integration has to be done so
how does that matter in this particular
case
so we'll see if i if i just go on to
simplify this thing
so let me just write that in the next
page
our gj is equal to
minus twice g are
summation i is equal to 1
to n that is over all the peripheries
the psi i integration
over the ith inner contour which has to
be done in a
clockwise in a clockwise fashion
x n x plus y
and y yes
and the last one is just
okay now let's take this up separately
over the cif contour we have x n x
plus y and y
yes let me mention this
integration and when i say
integration i mean this kind of a cyclic
line integration
uh over
each of the inner peripheries
has to be done
in a clockwise sense
simultaneously also i reiterate that the
integration over the outer periphery has
to be done
as we have been doing always in the
anti-clockwise sense
but right now i don't need to do that
because
all that remains is the inner
peripheries now
you see this x and x plus y and y
uh if we apply the
greens theorem here in reverse
in reverse means that we go to the step
we go back to the step where uh it
involves the derivatives
it should be like this that del del x of
x plus
del del y is a cyclic integration here
this is not
and this is this this won't be ci also
i'll correct that
so here we have gone from a line
integral
to an area integral correspondingly this
should be
changing to ai
okay so
this result is one
plus one
okay
now you may think
that uh all that you have to do here is
to write this as
twice a i that is fine
except for one little trouble in this
entire thing
is that this but when we when we had
said that this integration has to be
carried out uh in a clockwise sense that
clockwise sense
that has not been respected okay
so because it is a clockwise sense
so this should come out
in this kind of a negative sense okay
so it's better if we just keep it like
this and then we just
say that our result is actually minus
twice a
because of the clockwise sense
overall what does what does this give us
if we go back here the torsional
rigidity
now becomes four
g i i a
i
okay so we have this 2 here we have this
2 here that gives us a 4.
the g is already present and this ai is
here and this psi
i is very much present here so this is
psi i ai
please note that when
when we are doing actual problems you
must be extremely extremely careful
to note that this summation it goes over
all the uh peripheries
over all the inner peripheries okay you
have to
you should not include the outer
periphery okay
and i mean even if you did i mean
it is no problem because the psi would
contribute as 0
on the on the i equal to 0 all right
so this is 4g id
that's it okay so for for the multiply
connected region
we have to use this particular
expression
for the torsional rigidity
okay so this is something which we have
to be a little bit careful about
all right so on that note i will end
this video thank you very much